HEY.
- WHAT DO YOU WANT?
- I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
WE'RE HERE FOR YOU.
I'M HERE FOR YOU.
- HAVE YOU MADE
ANY SALES TODAY?
- OOH, YOU ARE ANGRY.
I LIKE THAT.
IF I GOT DIVORCED, I'D PROBABLY
BE PRETTY ANGRY, TOO.
FIRST I'D HAVE TO GET MARRIED,
BUT THEN...
- OH.
- IF I DID DIVORCE--
YOU NEED...
TO GET BACK ON THE MAN-HORSE,
RIGHT?
'CAUSE I THINK I KNOW
A CERTAIN HORSE-MAN
THAT MIGHT WANT TO TAKE YOU OUT
FOR A TROT.
- ARE YOU SERIOUSLY
HITTING ON ME RIGHT NOW?
- [horse whinny]
NAY.
NO, I'M NOT.
THAT WAS MY HORSE IMPRESSION
SAYING NO.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW,
WHAT KIND OF DUDES ARE YOU INTO?
- THESE.
I WANT A HOT-AS-BALLS
MALE MODEL.
- ARE YOU ONLINE DATING?
- I NEED TO HIRE A MODEL
FOR THE COMPANY WEBSITE,
YOU DUMMY.
- IS THAT RIGHT?